hello good morning welcome to saturday
morning we could be moving a step closer
to seeing an end to single-use plastics
in england the government's launching a
public consultation on banning items
such as single-use plates cutlery and
polystyrene cups in an effort to
eliminate all avoidable plastic waste
skies aisha zahid reports
at black sheep coffee sustainability is
at the heart of business everything they
use here is compostable their mission is
to keep plastic waste at bay
the social responsibility and
sustainability we think that it goes
together we source coffee in a
responsible way and we thought that we
we had to echo that in all the areas in
the company since day one we've been
like using non-plastic materials so if
we started
like that i think for any company that
wants to transition to non-plastic
materials is going to be easier
a ban on plastics is something people
here welcome
i avoid using it wherever possible so i
think if we didn't have it then we
wouldn't be able to use it would we
i think we've learned for a very long
time now that single-use plastics stay
in the environment for many many years
and they release greenhouse gases i
haven't been using those for a while now
and
i think they're quite a waste
so yeah let's just leave them
with the launch of a public consultation
in england we could be one step closer
to seeing single-use plastic cups
cutlery and plates banned as the
government pushes on with its battle
against plastic pollution with the aim
of eliminating avoidable waste by 2042
single-use plastics are a menace
and what we want to do is we want to
make sure that we can
get rid of those single-use plastics
that
actually are so difficult when you look
at how they affect both the marine
life when you look at how they affect
nature
but not everyone agrees with a blanket
ban
caroline's business relies on single-use
plastic she says there's more that needs
to be considered
when something is going to be banned
what is the alternative
and what is the implication of the
alternative so if we turn to wood as an
example
if you ban plastic cutlery and let's say
you need something that's single use and
you turn to wood
where does it come from it's coming from
trees
and if you look at cop26 one of the
agenda points was deforestation
while some businesses steam ahead for
others moving away from single-use
plastics will be a slower process
aisha tsar hits sky news
today us now and president biden has
urged americans to avoid violence and
destruction
it's after a teenager who killed two
people at a black lives matter protest
last year was acquitted of murder
carl rittenhouse's lawyers argued that
he was acting in self-defense when he
killed two men and injured another in
kenosha last august while troops from
america's national guard have been sent
to the city and made fears that a
verdict could provoke unrest from
wisconsin our u.s correspondents mark
stone reports
two weeks of evidence four days of jury
deliberation an eighteen-year-old in the
dock for murder and finally the verdicts
on five counts in a trial which has
gripped america as to the fifth count of
the information gage rose croix we the
jury find the defendant kyle avery kyle
h rittenhouse not guilty
carl rittenhouse faced a life sentence
and this the relief as he learned he was
free
there were times we doubted the case
there were times we were confident and
to say that we were relieved would be
a gross misunderstatement outside court
the divide this trial has exposed loud
and angry if i have a gun and you come
up on me and you try to cost me i'm
gonna use it that's the way it goes
around the corner the great aunt of
anthony huber one of the two men killed
by kyle rittenhouse and speechless ma'am
can you give us a sense of how you're
feeling
but on the other side of court mr
rittenhouse is family spokesman i
believe it represents a chance for this
country to
to have some discussions about how this
spun so far off the rails when it was
always about self-defense
it's a trial which has touched on so
many divisive issues race gun laws
disinformation politics and it's exposed
such differing views about what is right
and what is wrong it's liberal against
conservative american against american
and it's a snapshot of these divided
states
it all began last summer kenosha erupted
in black lives matter protests after the
shooting by police of black man jacob
blake
carl rittenhouse traveled from
neighboring illinois to counter the
protests claiming he was there to
protect businesses and offer medical
help he was armed with an ar-15 assault
rifle we don't have non-lethal
so you guys are full and ready to defend
the property
yes
this is the first man to be shot by mr
rittenhouse joseph rosenbaum part of the
black lives matter protest here kyle
rittenhouse is seen being chased by mr
rosenbaum a man nearby fires a handgun
into the air written house turns towards
the direction of gunfire mr rosenbaum
lunges at him and mr rittenhouse fires
four times hitting him in the head
he then runs down the road and trips as
he's chased by two other people anthony
huber is seen hitting him with a
skateboard ridden house shoots him from
the ground a third man gage gross croots
is also shot and injured
the defense presented him as a man
protecting a community from a mob and
shooting in self-defense
and this was the portrait the jury
believed
absorbing it outside the uncle of jacob
blake the man shot by police last august
it was terrible i mean there's nowhere
in the world uh you can watch two young
men get murdered on video just like you
saw a little jake get shot seven times
and there's no justice and with such a
different reflection mark mccloskey who
brandished his gun outside his home last
year and now running for the senate i
think it's a great day for for america i
think it's a great day for individual
liberty
justice ran its course in court in
kenosha but it is a justice that's
caused a deep sense of american
self-reflection
and mark has the latest now on the
reaction to that verdict well just as
this case has divided the nation so too
that thread runs through politics
president biden released a statement
shortly after the verdict came in and he
said while the verdict in kenosha will
leave many americans feeling angry and
concerned myself included we must
acknowledge that the jury has spoken i
know that we're not going to heal our
country's wounds overnight but i remain
steadfast in my commitment to do
everything in my power to ensure that
every american is treated equally with
fairness and dignity under the law and
former president donald trump who of
course has left it open as to whether he
may well run for president again in
three years time he released a statement
to the sentiment very different he said
congratulations to kyle rittenhouse for
being found innocent of all charges it's
called being found not guilty and by the
way if that's not self-defense nothing
is in terms of what happens now well i
think in the short term there is still
concern that there could potentially be
violence in this city and others across
the country longer term the question is
what precedent does this case set for
others and does it perhaps make some
people who are allowed to carry weapons
openly in some states are they going to
be emboldened to carry their weapons and
potentially to use them
that's mark stone there with the latest
from kenosha now police in the
netherlands have fired warning shots and
used water cannon on protesters after
rioting erupted in the city of rotterdam
over new coronavirus measures
hundreds had gathered to show their
anger as government plans for a covert
vaccine pass and a ban on fireworks on
new year's eve the netherlands imposed
the three-week partial covert lockdown
last week as cases surged it comes as
cases continue to rise across europe
in austria a full national lockdown will
begin on monday with chancellor
alexander schallenberg saying that it
would run for a maximum of 20 days the
country has become the first in europe
to make covert vaccines mandatory by law
germany has entered a nationwide state
of emergency because of surging
coronavirus infections
the head of the country's disease
control agency said that regular medical
care cannot be guaranteed anymore in
some parts of the country because of
hospitals and intensive care awards
being stretched
and boosters and third doses will now
show up automatically in the digital
path for people in england and from the
29th of november for people in wales
well joining us now for more is
professor john edmonds who's from the
school
london school of hygiene and tropical
medicine and a member of sage good
morning to you and thank you for your
time here on sky news this morning now
look we're looking at the current
situation in austria and zooming in on
the low vaccination rates and it makes
you wonder why so few people are taking
up the vaccine despite the government's
public service messages and campaigns
well it's a worry of course for them um
it's a worry here as well there's still
many millions of people here in the uk
have not been fully vaccinated
so you know it's it's essential now what
you see now in particular in central
europe with this very rapid increase in
cases you see the importance of of
vaccination how critical it is that
people who
uh
who need their boosters should come
forward as rapidly as possible and get
vaccinated and those who are still
unvaccinated then there are many
unfortunately out there
should really come forward and be
vaccinated as rapidly as possible
how worried should we be here in the uk
that something similar to what's
happening in australia on sorry in
austria and germany at the moment could
be just a matter of weeks away from here
well it shows how quickly things can go
wrong um what you're seeing in central
europe and many central european
countries as well as in other countries
around
so things can go wrong quite quickly
frankly here in the uk we've had high
rates of infection for many months now
so we're in a slightly different
position
to
austria and germany and so on
and that we've had high rates at fairly
stable but very high rates for many
months and so
i think
i don't think things will happen quite
in the same way here as they have done
there but it is a warning to us
so what about the booster program then
let's take a look at that do you think
that's going far enough or are you
concerned about waning
yes i'm concerned about waning immunity
i think it's pretty clear that when that
immunity does wane i'm sure that you
still have retained some protection from
the vaccine but it's about nowhere near
as strong as uh shortly after a vaccine
after you've been uh vaccinated and the
boosted doses it's pretty clear do give
a very a very clear what boost to your
immune system uh which may last for some
considerable time so i think
i i think it's really essential that the
the booster doses uh are rolled out as
fast as possible uh and i you know i
think it's
my own view i think we should be
probably looking to to boost everyone
who's been uh been vaccinated
now looking at our neighbors they are
obviously seeing a rise in cases so they
are imposing tougher measures but our
government obviously isn't following in
that direction is now time for plan b to
avoid us getting into the same situation
that they're in
well the plan b measures
um you know we could have implemented
them at any point because we've had high
rates of infection for as i say since
really june july
and those those plan b measures might
help somewhat at reducing uh infection i
think particularly working from home a
recommendation to work from home is
probably quite a uh effective one
uh it's a government decision whether to
to take that step of course they have to
they have to uh
you know look at the potential
effectiveness and and measure that
against the potential cost of some of
those things
professor john edmonds thank you very
much indeed for your time here on sky
news
well let's see how the weather is
shaping up
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well november has been very mild so far
hasn't he but it will turn much colder
during the weekend as northerly winds
bring a risk of frost and ice this will
be a wet and fairly breezy start today
for northern and western parts of
scotland elsewhere it will be mild but
mostly cloudy with some spots of drizzle
in the west and a band of rain will move
southeastwards across scotland northern
ireland and the republic reaching wales
and the midlands by saturday evening
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hundreds of millions of pounds of
taxpayers money is at increased risk
because of a failure to conduct proper
checks on green still capital that's
according to a committee of mps our
political correspondent rob pal has more
for us now so rob clearly this exposes a
lack of scrutiny doesn't it yeah and
you'll remember greenfield capital um
was in the news earlier um this year
because it was the firm that the former
prime minister david cameron um worked
for and advised and lex green sill um
the founder of that company was also
an advisor to david cameron when he was
in downing street now david cameron got
into a spot of bothered by
trying to lobby ministers to get access
for green sale capital to get access to
some of the coveted loan schemes now
while
some of those were rejected it did get
access to some of those schemes
and was allowed to essentially use
government money to lend out to
businesses to help them get through the
pandemic now the issue is that green
sill capital went bust in march this
year
and that means that hundreds of millions
of pounds around 335 million pound chunk
of cash
that was
loaned and guaranteed by the government
could now fall back on the taxpayer
to foot that bill and what the public
accounts committee has been looking at
across party group of mps
is whether enough scrutiny was done on
green sill capital before it was
accredited
as a lender and this is what the chair
of the committee dave mchillier has said
at the beginning of the pandemic the
priority for all the loan schemes we've
looked at for small and large businesses
was speed over checks so while some
checks were carried out but what you
might call the common sense ones the
smell test ones were ones that didn't
seem to take place from what we can see
so press reports uh questions about what
was happening across government there
seems to be very little sharing of the
information about government about
concerns about within particular green
school capital
now a lot of the criticism from the
committee falls at the door of the
british business bank which is basically
a government-owned bank that was
responsible for checking out and vetting
companies before it approved them as
lenders now the committee's report said
that
the
bank's
scrutiny of greenville capital you can
see lex greensteal and david cameron
there was woefully um inadequate and
that the bank was insufficiently curious
about reports that greenfield capital
was close to collapse now the british
business bank has has provided a
statement in response
it's referred to another report that was
compiled by the national audit office
previously and it said that uh in which
it said the british business bank
appropriately applied a streamlined
version of its established process when
it's accredited green sale capital
limited as a lender under the covert 19
business support schemes a less
streamlined accreditation process would
have meant fewer lenders would have been
accredited and fewer businesses would
have received the critical emergency
finance they needed during the pandemic
so
it's sort of a familiar story along
similar lines to the ones we hear about
which companies are given contracts to
do things like testing valuable
contracts for covert testing contracts
to provide protective equipment and it's
essentially that balance between needing
to act quickly in the midst of a public
health emergency but then also needing
to be careful with what you're doing
with taxpayer cash and what this
committee
of mps is saying in relation to green
silk capital
is that the british business bank got
that balance wrong on this occasion
dartmouth line rail service between
exeter and oakhampton is reopening to
passengers for the first time in nearly
50 years making it the first line to be
reinstated under the department for
transport restoring your railway
initiative well our correspondent either
bennett joins us us live now from
oakhuntin either good morning to you why
this station
[Music]
yes
welcome to oakhampton train station in
dartmouth where passenger services the
regular passenger service has just
resumed for the first time uh in nearly
50 years i'm afraid i can't actually
show you any trains because the first
service has just come and gone it's just
departed back to exeter making the
40-minute trip back down the line it
departed around uh a minute ago so i
can't show you any trains but i can tell
you about them the first one rolled in
around 20 minutes ago it was packed with
lots of rail enthusiasts young families
out for a day trip here in dartmouth a
lot of hikers about to go for a walk on
the moors which are literally
just a stone's throw away it's seen as a
really significant moment for this local
community it's part of the government's
plans
to restore uh train lines and rail
services that were scrapped in the 60s
and 70s as part of the beaching cuts
cuts that were known as the beaching
cuts
so a really significant moment is
not at an insignificant cost though 40
million pounds and to tell us more about
what that money was spent on i am joined
by stuart calvert from network rail
stuart thanks for speaking to us um
so what is exactly involved in restoring
a rail service like this what was that
money spent on so it's it's a mixture of
engineering a lot of engineering
obviously we've got a railway line here
where we had to do a lot of drainage
works the most significant work was a
lot of track renewal and and we set some
records here actually it was 11 miles of
track which is 29 000 tons of ballast 24
000 sleepers and we relayed that in four
weeks so the whole engineering has only
taken eight months just over eight
months from when we got funding drainage
radio systems bit of signaling work and
then around the station here you can see
the work we've done the station which is
looking beautiful today and why restore
this line who's going to be using it
well look there's people around here
have been campaigning for this line to
be reopened ever since it's shut in
1972. it serves uh the north of dartmoor
which hasn't been served by rail so it
will serve three things mainly ledger
people coming to the moor people
commuting into extra are going into
extra shopping and academic users
students and so on so it serves all
sorts of things but it opens up a part
of dartmoor that hasn't been served by
rail for a long time all right thanks
stuart now and this does of course come
in the same week that the government uh
was accused of breaking its promises
on rail services in other parts of the
country in the north of england saying
it was scrapping the eastern leg of hs2
so i think a lot of people who are angry
about that may well be asking why this
line was restored but nevertheless this
is a significant moment for the local
community here
iva thank you
now as a result of climate change and
the loss of habitat the koala population
of new south wales in australia has
reached a tipping point
a new report is warning that the animals
could be extinct in the state by the
year 2050. siobhan robbins has this
report from sydney
okay 835 grams weighing less than a bag
of sugar koala joey dara is having a
checkup look in your mouth
she and her injured mother were rescued
from a sydney roadside a month ago
climate change and rapid urbanization
are putting the whole species under
threat
with warnings they could be extinct in
new south wales by 2050
this is unprecedented and we're in
tipping point times more trees are being
cut down more areas are being built up
we're having
huge fires and and all these things
eventually will will have major impact
not just on koalas but all the other
animals that live in the same habitat
that they do
do you know if this coil is injured no i
don't so the first point of what we do
is we assess to make sure the koala is
fit and fine and okay without any
injuries volunteer tracy is responding
to a growing number of koala call outs
the adrenaline kicks into them and they
just want to get away from whatever it
is that's into them
the young koala is worryingly close to a
busy road and houses it's not rapid
breathing
rapid breathing would would tell me it's
heat stress and also that there may be
an injury
it appears unhurt but the team will
patrol to make sure it stays away from
the traffic
this is a perfect example of the
pressure that our lives put on koalas
lives the more we encroach in their
territory the higher the risk is
estimated every year four thousand are
killed by dogs and on the road
climate change is another threat
wildfires killed thousands of the
state's koalas in 2019.
sydney's last healthy and thriving
colony live in the trees you can see
here
but developers have been given
permission to build thousands of homes
nearby
why build on an area which is so close
to a very active koala population so the
project is really focusing on developing
on areas that have been cleared for some
time
and as a result of that we're able to
then enhance and protect areas of
existing habitat to provide more habitat
and better connections for the
population
the state government and developers say
they're committed to protecting koalas
with inclusions like animal underpasses
fences and conservation zones but
campaigners are scathing if you were
trying to wipe out koalas in new south
wales you would do exactly what the new
south wales government is doing you
would find the habitat where they are
surviving and succeeding and you would
start to declare that as housing
the last three years it's feared new
south wales has lost around 40 percent
of its koalas
unhindered
drought disease and development
could mean they disappear completely
siobhan robbins sky news in sydney
all right let's see how the weather is
looking today
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well here's the good news november has
been very mild so far but and there's
always a bus isn't there it will turn
much colder during the weekend as
northerly winds bring a risk of frost
and ice it will be a wet and fairly
breezy start today for northern and
western parts of scotland elsewhere it
will be mild but mostly cloudy with some
spots of drizzle in the west
a band of rain will move southeastwards
across scotland northern ireland and the
republic reaching wales and the midlands
by saturday evening ahead of that much
of england and wales will be mostly dry
and mild if rather cloudy
sunny spells and scattered showers will
follow for scotland and northern ireland
but it will turn noticeably colder here
the cold air will feed further south
overnight as the rain band continues
southwards many inland areas will have
clear spells with showers mainly around
the coasts
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways with us this
morning to review the papers our
broadcaster and writer edward ado and
former editor of the daily star dawn
nissan good morning to you both looking
lovely this morning let's just get
straight into it i must say um dawn i'll
start with you um colin pitchfork who um
is going back inside tell us why
yeah absolutely this is the um splash on
today's daily mirror and stories also
inside in several other newspapers and
it is it's a horrible story really and
it's not great we're talking about it
but this is slightly different anyways
um double child killer college pitchfork
um has been recalled to prison just two
months after release
um i'm just reminding people that he was
jailed for life in 1988 for raping and
strangling two 15 year old girls
he was released on a very very
controversial parole in september
and
has been evidently according to people
in the in the safe house the parole
board house he was living in um was seen
approaching young girls which is a
breach of the very very strict
conditions he was supposed to be living
under which is why he has been sent back
to prison vanessa and uh
and hopefully we'll we'll i mean i've
got to say it we'll never see the light
of day again i mean i i
there was so much controversy
controversy when he was released from
prison because it had been refused
parole um in 2016 and 2018
and there was a lot of complaints about
why he was allowed out this time because
he doesn't seem to be safe and this
seems to be proving that he cannot be
trusted back on the streets you know
that's what they were young girls um and
that's what he was seeing i mean he has
some of the strictest curfew conditions
um um in the country i mean most people
have several you have 35 additional ones
on them so i think you know it's an
awful story but i just you know i'm glad
it's back behind ours and that young
girls now are safe and you know it's
just
well good riddance to bad rubbish
absolutely and and edward it does
beg the question why was he even
released in the first place
no of course i think this is where
possibly an investigation or questions
need to be asked as dawn was saying you
know parole refused a number of times
and for him to be on the streets and
obviously what he's been doing recently
it questions the whole system as to you
know why he was um allowed why he was
set free in in the first place and um
what was done in order to um to lead the
lead up to him being released i think
loads of questions have to be asked and
so that it doesn't happen again and
obviously if it in in terms of uh rehab
for him and other prisoners
of that ilk um that certainly needs to
be questioned as well i mean the whole
thing it just it's it's an absolute fast
absolutely um edward i'll stay with you
because this story is just growing and
growing it's not going to go away until
we see
penguin what's going on here
so this is the story about the tennis
player um the allegation of sexual
assault by a chinese uh premier so it's
the the welfare famous uh
tennis player who no one seems to know
where she is now there's reports saying
that she's um at she she's at home she's
safe and there will be a statement
made in a couple of what in a couple of
days but the question is i mean it's
it's caused
it's it's lots of
the the the american government the uk
basically lots of governments have said
uh where is she we want to get answers
this is not right
for her to be in a sense we don't know
we can't speculate but it seems that she
is somewhere um
we don't know her state but from
according to sources from the chinese
government who have said um
she's in a safe place
it's just a worrying story and also i
think the
the kind of top line of this story um as
soon as the allegation was made again we
we can't speculate it was taken offline
and she disappeared
absolutely and then of course we had
those um statements of her saying oh i'm
absolutely fine it's okay don't worry
about me are you buying that dawn
there was this weird picture that was
issued of her covering a cat wasn't
there and he just none of it makes sense
we do know and i don't think it's
controversial that china do not have a
great history of human rights do they
you know she's she's a top-ranked player
in the women's doubles i mean she won't
have women in 2013 the french open in
2014 she's also participated in three
olympics making her
her disappearance a very prominent issue
bearing in mind that the winter olympics
are due to be held in beijing in
february
so it's his you know you can't help but
worry about what has happened to her and
sort of like pray she is safe but
it's you know her disappearance will be
increasing pressure on china ahead of
the games and and surely that must be a
good thing absolutely and i'll stay with
you dawn because let's talk about amazon
which usually hits the headlines now
this is not a good one so 10 hours shift
stuck inside a cage and this is um
amazon slaves
and then there's a picture of course of
um
jeff bezos who continues to make a lot
of money so much so
he pops into space just a few weeks ago
didn't he
well quite absolutely
i mean this is an interview a very very
shocking interview with a a a lady
called olivia she's in her 30s um she's
she's remaining anonymous for obvious
reasons and she was um
doing [ __ ] um in amazon the run up to
christmas very busy time of year
obviously and you know she was doing
eight months of grooming shift standing
nine pounds seventy an hour and you know
working in a cage melissa she had a what
they described as a workstation but it's
basically you're in a cage and you're
staring at a computer and you have to
meet so many targets your your lube
rates are monitored you have to get
permission to go to the mood you're
filmed every step of the way of what
you're doing it just sounds horrendous
and the problem is with lockdown
business we've all got hooked on
ordering stuff online and as much as you
know we all think right okay amazon
they're not really a great company i
mean bearing in mind the uk outfit pays
less than four million pounds
corporation tax despite 1.9 billion
sales rise last year um so it's not
great and you really try and stop
yourself to ordering things from amazon
um but it's we're all addicted on it
thanks to blooming lockdown so i'm going
to try now and use my local high street
and local shops more because you can't
have people working in these conditions
in 2021 absolutely absolutely and
awareness of that as well now edward i'm
going to come to the area of music and
ed sheeran um in particular and he's his
back at accusations that he appropriated
right grind music to boost his career
and you just kind of think you know he's
just a great singer doing great things
and he recently did some collaborations
with some western african singers
for ghana in west africa and it was
celebrated can't he just be celebrated
that's the problem i think for some
artists if you jump on a particular
genre for whether it be grime or whether
it be hip-hop or drama bass or any other
genre and if you happen to to be white
some people say oh well it's culture
appropriation i think this is an
accusation that has been made here and
ed sheeran has has called out um the the
the artist wiley and said look he's made
um
accusations in the past about this
ed sheeran he was nominated for a mobile
he won the black power list for one
extra in 2014. as he rightly said
vanessa he is a great musician and in
what he what he's done over the years um
is he's just super talented i don't
think whether he's made grime music or
any other genre that shouldn't be
questioned i think some people tend to
sort of put this on the table because
they might be um
they might be jealous they might be
angry of what he what what he's done i
think as an artist he should be
celebrated and you know talking about
cultural appropriation when it comes to
music i mean if if that's the case we'll
be here all day musicians should be
allowed to do what they do i mean
there's a classic jazz musician bob
james who's made the finest jazz music
ever and you know when people found out
that you know bob james was white they
didn't question it they celebrated his
music i mean we could name numerous
white artists who have made some
incredible music which is in a senses
push black music and in a sense they
they would say they're just doing it
because they love and appreciate that
the genres and the music and what they
do it's a it's about
it's it's it's one of these stories
which i'm sure
it will surface again but it's just
annoying that we're even talking about
it music is music absolutely i can think
of ub40 in the song red red wine which
we will not be having this morning we
will leave it for the evening
put it down dawn
what do you make of it
you know this whole argument of cultural
appropriation
oh well look vanessa i'm just so look
you know as edwards just said it is
music it is one of the joyous things
that unites us all we should all
celebrate it i mean you know i'm a huge
fan of the rolling stones and the
rolling stones you know sort of like you
know they they popularized blues music
which i know they came from sort of like
you know black musicians and it was like
what is wrong with you know paying
tribute to other artists to enjoying it
that's just why does everything vanessa
these days have to come down to division
and hatred and everybody having a go at
someone about something or other
everyone's permanently offended about
something these days aren't they but
this is just music you know let's just
kind of enjoy ourselves absolutely and
if people keep going on about it i'm
gonna sing okay and nobody wants to hear
that we want you to sing
vanessa we want you to sing don't you
dare you can do it this morning
let's do it honestly it's a threat that
i'm putting out there one day i will
belt something out
and um just very quickly dawn um benny
hills some of his um
you know some of his past work is you
know his past work obviously is coming
to the fall tell us more yeah absolutely
the benny hill show is back this was
obviously hugely popular um in the 70s
it's uh um and it was sort of
semi-cancelled because of woke culture
and it's that word again i know but i
mean it was it was deemed to be
offensive but i mean it's just fun i
loved it i know edward loved it as well
he got together for actually watching it
and you know the thing i really liked
about the benny hill show it's coming
back by the way on oh what's tv channel
is it coming back on
i can't find that tv i think that's tv
that's the one that's it
you know the thing i really liked about
it and edward won't like this bit it's
like you know what and yeah there was
scantily clad ladies in there but they
were all gorgeous you know what but they
were the ones in charge they made the
men look pretty silly in that
i think that can't be a bad thing
and oh my goodness edward we don't have
time to go into detail but the story in
the guardian is that chocolate is good
for us it's good for the heart so we
can't complain chocolate is good dark
chocolate is good for the heart so
apparently a specialist who is he's
endorsed this and said it's better than
having wine and he backs coffee as well
and i can certainly endorse that because
there's a particular brand and because
we're on sky news i'm not going to
mention it but i tend to have at least a
box every day which is not good but i
still managed to
it looks slimline which is fantastic so
please if you if you can get it i wish i
could tell you the problem
dark chocolate is good for you edward
thank you so much see you soon